so in Mesoamerican cosmology in its
creation stories which there are many
types there's one theme that really
helps us understand divination and
prediction practices among the Aztecs
and the Maya and the story goes that
that in the beginning as in many
paradisiacal stories in the beginning
there was a period of time where heaven
and earth were close together where he
where the beings who existed could could
speak to animals where divinities and
humans were almost on the same plane
ancestor our ancestors and divinities
were close and they all had the same
powers of seeing of observing but in the
Mesoamerican case what happens is the
deities for some reason they become
jealous at the ancestors who are closer
to humans who've not yet been created
have the same powers that they have and
they decide that they don't like this
and so they create a separation and the
way they create the separation is they
cast a spell over the vision over the
eyes of the ancestors and which is
described as though a breath on a mirror
and there's still a mirror but when the
ancestors and eventually the humans look
into the mirror they can't see as
clearly they can't see as far into the
mirror they can't see themselves they
can't see the world and therefore what
happens is that when human beings are
created they inherit its breath over the
mirror of their eyes and they can still
see the world that all of us see but in
fact the world is so much more full of
life it's all around that we can't see
and therefore the divinities can see
they can see inside of trees they can
see inside of our bodies they can see
through mountains they can see great
distances all things that we cannot do
and so what happens is
that certain individuals in the society
are are born who have a little bit more
capacity for vision and those often
become the diviners they have to undergo
training special training to take this
extra ability to see that moves them a
little closer to the ancestors or to the
divinities and they take this training
will be quite close shamanistic training
to sharpen this ability and they're
often the ones who who can read the sign
to become the diviners but this idea of
the mirror is very important in Mexico
in Mesoamerica because many of these
mirrors were made out of obsidian this
black obsidian stone that was very
brittle and very sharp it could be
shined could shine it and when you look
into it I've looked into them you can
you can see yourself now you can't see
themself as clearly as when we look into
our mirrors but you can you can see so
yourself and sometimes you can see
things behind you and so these mirrors
become very important for humans as
techniques to improve their own ability
to see by having these mirrors it
improves clarifies that breathily on the
eyes
you